this is the mariana trench the deepest
place on earth
it stretches 11 kilometers down below
sea level but
what if
we made it even deeper
well get a giant drill because we're
about to dig a hole in one of the most
hostile environments on the planet
has anyone attempted to do this before
what kind of nasty conditions would you
be stepping into
and
could you drill all the way to the
earth's core
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you drilled a hole at the
bottom of the mariana trench
here in the western pacific the mariana
trench isn't the most popular travel
spot
it's frigid and bone-crushingly deep not
something you'd pick for your vacation
so it's not surprising that only a
handful of people have ever visited it
it's a long way to the challenger deep
the deepest part of the mariana trench
drilling through it would be both
expensive and dangerous
you'd need to troubleshoot on the spot
work in complete darkness and survive
cold temperatures
you might not come back safe and sound
okay now that we've sparked your
interest it's time to buckle down and
get to work
it would be costly to get to the bottom
but it would be even more expensive to
start drilling through it you'd need
very specialized equipment
while the water temperature around you
would be just above freezing
you'd need to worry more about the
crushing pressure
at the bottom of the mariana trench it
would be 1100 times the atmospheric
pressure at sea level
you wouldn't be able to survive in just
a diving scene
you'd need to jump into a submarine
designed to withstand such high pressure
and all the drilling equipment would
need to be specifically designed for the
depth
before you could start drilling you'd
have another issue
there would be no way to anchor your
expensive drilling equipment at the
bottom of the mariana trench
you'd need to find a way to stabilize
your rig
and if that's not bad enough you'd need
to assemble everything on site yeah
you'd be moving heavy pipes and drills
around and you'd need to bring some
powerful lights because
it would be dark
the mariana trench is just too deep for
sunlight to reach
okay once you dealt with all that you
could start drilling
and that endeavor would bring even more
surprises
we know more about the surface of the
moon that we know about earth's ocean
floor
but one thing we do know is that it can
get hot
in 2011 researchers drilled the japan
trench just outside of japan
they went down 6.9 kilometers and found
that the temperature below the seafloor
was scorching
at just one kilometer down the
temperature reached
120 degrees celsius
another challenge you'd face would be
the ocean crust itself
it's composed of igneous rock or
hardened magma
this would wear down your drill pretty
quickly
you'd need to keep replacing your drill
bit
and you better mark the hole with a
re-entry cone
at the bottom of the ocean it would be
tough to find the spot you'd already
been drilling
it would be like lowering a long strand
of spaghetti into a 0.6 centimeter
funnel at the deep end of an olympic
swimming pool
yeah that's hard
so just how deep into the earth's crust
would you be able to drill
well that depends
how patient are you
and how much money do you have to spend
on all that drilling equipment
if you're thinking about drilling all
the way to the earth's core
forget it
oddly enough drilling through the crust
from the deepest place on earth
wouldn't help you get to the core faster
no that's because earth isn't perfectly
spherical yeah it bulges at the equator
making the drilling distance to the
center of the earth from the mariana
trench
longer
if you wanted to drill all the way
through the earth you'd be better off
starting your project near the pole says
they are closer to the earth's core
but you know what
i'll leave that story
for another
what if
[Music]